hello good afternoon my name is uh eric
festraz i am president of the fiber to
the home council europe
i would like to welcome you to this
webinar which is called accelerate fiber
broadband monetization this is a webinar
that is organized by nokia
first a few words around the fiber to
the home council europe we are an
industry association founded in 2004
with a mission to advance ubiquity's
full favor based on a full fiber-based
connectivity to the whole of europe
we have more than 150 member companies
which is vendors operators and investors
and our activities include expert advice
to policy makers and regulators
studies and reports
networking platform available for all
members and on members
and an annual ftth conference where you
see a picture here our last one was in
last may in vienna
the fiber to the home council organizers
as well what we call sponsored webinars
and these are a series of fiber industry
webinars by providing a focused audience
specifically on fiber specifically of
industry especially
stakeholders
and it is promoted by the highly
respected industry association
that we are
some practical information before we
start and dive into the content the
webinar will be recorded and is
accessible digitally after the session
um given we have received your consent
you will be notified about future ftth
council europe webinar series events
and you may pose your questions uh
during the webinar in the question
section you have here on the platform
and share the time permitted
then the moderator which uh the role i'm
playing here will share your questions
uh with the speakers okay
so that being said
i would like to pre pre
present you the topics of this session
so accelerate fiber broadband
monetization is a title
merely we talk about advances in fiber
technology enabling new services and
resulting in more revenue streams and
the bulk of the presentation will be
around how to offer promote drive
adoption and accelerate monetization of
fiber broadband
it will be all around best practices
from expert speakers
of this session that you see both them
and myself
the two speakers um quickly on myself
i'm president of the fiber to the home
council europe but within my nokia job
i'm director of strategic marketing of
the fixed networks division
uh we are delighted to have uh benoit
here with us bernard pilgrim who was
distracted in his fields for more than a
decade
he came back after 10 years with asia
back to europe
and is now working for plum consulting
and we are very happy that he will share
his expertise with us
a bit a bit later in this presentation
welcome everyone
well the title of the presentation is
accelerate fiber broadband monetization
now
i would not be the president of the 500
home council europe if i would not say
that fiber is there for everything not
only to the home
but in fact to
all sorts of segments that we discover
in the market today
it is clear as setting the scene that
fiber is the future and network
providers are investing
fiber is the fastest growing access
technology we see vr analysts that today
60 of all fixed broadband is fiber
and we expect 70 in a couple of years
from now
it is the most future-proof and greenest
technology and above all
once the outside plant is deployed you
do not need to touch again
that outside plant you can move ahead
and move ahead and move ahead
so these elements are very clear in the
market i don't have to convince anyone
on this
but we start to think differently
about fiber broadband
we see this evolution of these passive
optical network pond technologies as we
call them from g-pawn to excess pawn to
25 week and later 50 gig and 100 gig
which gives us a lot of other
opportunities and also other revenues
potential revenues that we can get on
the network
that's why we state that it is one
single infrastructure
to connect everything
and everyone
and fiber infrastructure is indeed
therefore more than only residential
as i said at the beginning you invest
once and you monetize again and again
and again and it starts of course with
residential broadband
and that of course reaches uh the bulk
of your your consumers in the market
but on that same infrastructure you can
also offer business services
and there with with fiber you can have
dedicated internet connectivity but we
more and more now move to moving from
point to point fiber to also point a
multi-point type of fiber connectivity
to more business broadband which is not
having necessarily the same sla as the
pure point-to-point but with decent and
very acceptable in the market type of
sla and quality of service
you can go to wholesale you can offer
connectivity to isps over your network
you can also wholesale to
to enterprises for instance
um you can cover mobile transport over
that same fiber infrastructure which is
happening today already in a lot of
cases that will happen more and more
cloud gaming immersive entertainment all
these things where you need more and
more let's say symmetrical latency
sensitive type of traffic also that
traffic can cover to be covered over
your fiber infrastructure not to even
talk about all the smart city type of
applications you could ever imagine
i heard even yesterday that chorus new
zealand for instance will do the
monitoring uh over city cctv with all
their rail transport road network
because they do not think that wireless
is reliable enough no they do it with
fiber in the whole city of oakland for
instance now
that being said fiverr is there for more
than only residential
but if you think about the residential
mindset than you say we are deploying
gpon
and of course with gpon you see that
your first the first year you have an
investment to be made
and then you see that after something
like seven years you start to be
positive
on your capability of discounted cash
flow
but as i said there are new bond
technologies that
like
one for instance exespond that gives you
much more
possibilities and opportunities to have
new revenues and new services which
gives you a little additional investment
at the beginning but then brings forward
the
number of years in which you can get
on top of the bar and being positive on
your return on investment
you can even with a slight even
additional improvement with 25 bit bomb
for instance say that you have a higher
cash flow and your break even moves to
five years instead of seven years this
is of course a generic case every
business case is different but you can
clearly see
the uh
the main lines of that economical
analysis
one single fiber infrastructure for all
services and one converged network
that we all know we all we all believe
that and we all with that you see that
more revenues lower tto if you use one
fiber network a converse network all
that is very clear
but you see that there are now a lot
more
by the spawn evolution a lot more
possibilities
a lot more opportunities and a lot more
network parameters there is high
capacity you can move as i said from g
pawn to xds pawn to 25 gigabomb
the opportunity to have low latency so
sub millisecond latency
not even to talk about about even lower
if you talk about 5g front hole type of
solutions for instance remember mobile
transport also fiber latency becomes
very important
the automation as well with the move to
software defined access networks you're
going to decouple effect software
hardware from each other make it more
simple make it much more automated move
to zero touch provisioning and these
kind of things
the mission critical aspect
not even to forget we tend to link it to
health care and emergency and typical
very sensitive business type of
applications
but now after the covet pandemic every
house starts to be in fact
a mission-critical connectivity
because
you work from home you live at home so
that
importance of that connectivity at home
starts to be of utmost importance more
and more
and then the green aspect power
consumption
is also a very important
aspect the sustainability of fiber
access networks is proven that it's far
better than with other access networks
network technologies and we see that the
power consumption if you move to one
full one fiber access network effect
goes seven to ten times lower than if
you would combine all these different uh
different networks
so i think
it's clear
that one fiber infrastructure with all
these new pawn technologies on top of it
creating lots of opportunities
opportunities for monetizing
and at the end network providers are not
in the network for only charity they are
in the network there to gain money to
create revenue and to be successful
there
and that's why we look very carefully
into fiverr strategies for monetization
first of all you need to enhance your
consumer services is what we call
gigabit monetization and i come to that
in a minute but also to enlarge the
service portfolio
not only residential as i said business
wholesale mobile and all the 4.0
industry type of applications you see
coming up there
so there are two access we we see that
clearly moving into what we would like
to focus now on
is on the first part enhancing the
consumer services because they are still
a lot to grain as well
and
today for instance we see that most of
the service providers
they have gigabit offers in their
portfolio
now
over to you can we say that the fixed
broadband market is in the era of
gigabit now today
uh
not exactly because it's true that
um something like um 60 of service
providers worldwide now offer gigabit
uh connectivity but if you start
drilling down and looking at exactly how
many people are subscribing the number
is much much lower
now uh very few operators actually
officially report that number
but from various conversations that i've
had with service providers around the
world
the number that i come around is 15 to
20 so in other words when there is a
gigabit offer
available on a network on average only
15 to 20 of consumers
actually subscribe to that gigabit offer
and uh this to me is a very important
finding because
um
gigabit has been on the market for 15
years now i mean the earliest operators
who launched gigabit were in a
2005-2006 era now of course they were
trailblazers at the time
but it's it's a little
concerning to me that we still have such
a low percentage of customers who
actually
subscribe to gigabit
and why aren't they pushing them for
gigabit why aren't they doing that
well
there's a number of possible reasons
um i think first of all because they
don't really want to
um
or at least they don't implement
strategies that would lead to that goal
there are exceptions of course and in
fact there are a few operators that we
studied uh that only have gigabit offers
or more so obviously they have a 100
take-up rate on gigabit but for the most
part um you don't see a concerted
strategy to upsell customers
to gigabit
um
but
beyond that there are also i think some
old ways of doing things that are still
pro
prevalent and and are not
fully adapted to
the challenges of the upsell so for
example a lot of operators and i'll come
back to that in a minute a lot of
operators have a lot of offers
uh way too many offers
um and that creates uh customer
confusion because when you're going to
subscribe you don't really know
uh the difference between all of this
and
also it creates caution so customers are
a lit a little more reluctant to
uh to go forward because
they feel like
operators are trying to
hide something or
maybe not deliver as good as they're
saying they will
so all of that is an issue pricing of
course is an issue as well
in many many offers
uh we saw in the previous slide that a
lot of operators
only have speeds up to a gigabit uh in
many many offers gigabit is the highest
speed tier
uh and it's
packaged as a premium offer so
uh the the price differential is is very
high
um and one thing i heard from a number
of operators which i find very ironic
is this fear of tomorrow's upsell so
this idea that basically if i push all
my customers to gigabit today what am i
going to sell them tomorrow
and uh to me that's a very short-term
view on the market
we know that xgs pawn is being deployed
today we know that 25 gpon is ready for
deployment and it will be deployed
by some operators in the next few years
so
purely in terms of speed there is no
reason why customers would say well i've
got a gigabit i'll never go beyond in
fact uh i did a study 10 years ago for
the council on the swedish market and
we asked gigabit customers back then
if they were willing to
uh purchase higher speed tiers which
didn't exist at the time and 14 of
gigabit customers were saying
i want to buy a higher speed tier so
there's no reason to fear this but it's
in the marketing of a lot of operators
there's this element of
what am i going to sell tomorrow
and so rather than rather than sell
today i protect myself by not selling
today which to me is an absurd
proposition
yeah
i understand understand but it is
essentially then a price issue in fact
well that would be probably the first
and and and
biggest issue but the price element
itself is actually driven by
a number of things and one of those is
the segmentation so um anyone who's been
to marketing school as i have knows that
you're drilled in this marketing theory
that an optimal segmentation is how you
make the most
revenue out of a given market and so
there is kind of a
uh um
an urge in marketing teams to segment as
far as they can but i think there is
such a thing as too much segmentation
because when
consumers no longer perceive the
difference between two offers then
you've gone too far in the segmentation
and here we're talking about broadband
speeds and it's quite clear to me that
while you will perceive a difference as
a user if you switch from 100 make to a
gig
you might not perceive a difference if
you switch from 500 to a gig or from 100
to 200 and so having an excessive number
of speed tiers actually muddies the
water entirely and consumers then end up
saying well
maybe what i have is good enough i'm not
sure i need more because they don't see
what they're going to get from these
higher speed tiers
so what we see here for example is that
on average
service providers offer
a little over three
fiber broadband plans but that's the
average and that includes companies as i
mentioned who only have one speed tier
so in reality what we're looking at is
closer to four on average and that's a
little bit higher for incumbent
operators who tend to segment more
and we've seen in our sample that we've
studied
we've seen operators with up to six
different speed plans
between a hundred and a gig
and and that to me is is crazy because
not only does it mean the consumers no
longer see the difference but it also
means that you have to manage
space in your pricing plan for all of
these
different plans and that means that
mathematically that pushes up the
gigabit to prices that are simply
too high
so
like uh what we've looked at here is
we've looked at the difference between
the entry-level
fiber offer
which is usually 100 meg but in some
instances can be a little lower than
that
and the gigabit plan
and what we see is that on average the
price difference is 45
so a gigabit on average is 45 more
expensive than 100 make
right with incumbents again that that
gap is a little higher so it tends to be
50
but in our sample and we looked at about
25 different operators uh in our sample
we have four operators where the price
gap is a hundred percent so the gigabit
cost is double the hundred make
and uh
that price gap is clearly clearly too
high and you can see here on the left on
that graph you can see
the direct impact of the number of plans
on the gap in pricing basically if you
have one or two plans
your price gap is around 20
if you have more than that your price
gap is around 50 to 60 percent
um now
i've heard uh marketing people within
service operators say but i'm delivering
10 times the speed so in theory i could
ask for 10 times the price but that's an
absurd proposition because what the
consumer is buying is not the speed
itself it's
everything that that speed enables and
also
and i'll come back to that in a minute
but we have to remember
that once you've actually built your
fiber network
upgrading a customer from a hundred make
to a gig
has virtually zero cost attached to it
and so
we have here a classic case of a price
that becomes completely decorated from
its cost base
and that creates a disincentive for
consumers to migrate
sure
i understand
so
this is how service providers have
segmented in fact and and priced their
offerings
maybe it's not in their interest to them
up till to gigabit for instance or is it
well
i think that's part of the problem is
that they don't necessarily think that
it is but i i think that it is i think
it's in their interest for one very
simple reason which is based on what i
said earlier which is that the cost to
upsell to gigabit is virtually zero
basically it's a tiny little bit more of
energy cost each month
and it's a tiny little bit more of
transit
cost each month we're talking literally
cents
per subscriber per month now
historically
in the initial deployments a lot of
onts were not gigabit compatible so you
also had to upgrade the ont but now
every ont that's out on the market is
gigabit compatible so that's no longer a
hurdle um so basically what i see in the
market is that a lot of the operators
uh see this as premium so they're going
to put a high arpu uplift but address a
small part of the customer base where in
fact they could have a small rpu uplift
and upsell to a large part of the
customer base now in terms of revenue
that would look roughly the same
but the thing is that in order to build
these premium gigabit offers
they
pack in a lot of additional services
that actually cost
either to produce or to buy so for
example if you look around at the
premium gigabit offers of a lot of
operators you'll have netflix included
disney plus included some iptv solutions
all of these things are actually eating
into your margin so
in revenue terms a naked gigabit offer
that would be
you know 20 percent
more expensive than your 100 meg offer
versus a premium offer that would be 50
more expensive actually
you would if you market the gigabit
offer properly the naked gigabit offered
properly you would be generating pure
additional margin
whereas in the premium case
not only are you addressing a much
smaller part of your customer base but
you're actually not generating full
margin because you have all these
additional services that you have to uh
pay for
um the other thing of course is that
if you're not aggressive on gigabit
someone else will be right so
this is the story of
of dsl in france right when
when free came on the market they said
you will have the high speed we can
offer no matter what and when they
started deploying fiber they did the
same so basically
everyone is competing against a higher
speed offer that's at the same price or
even cheaper now maybe that's not the
case in your market but it could very
well become that
anyone who's deploying xgspawn today is
going to be thinking okay so if i can
now have gigabit as the base feed for my
customers how do i articulate a market
strategy around that to actually acquire
new consumers new customers
so if you're not doing it someone else
will and it's a bad thing in any market
to be the second one to launch what's
perceived as an innovation by the
consumers
absolutely absolutely
now we talk of course about retail but
do we see the same trends if we look to
the uh the wholesale market for instance
so
not exactly it's it's it's quite
interesting a few of the wholesalers
are replicating basically what we're
seeing on the retail side on the
wholesale side but there are exceptions
and there are actually quite a few
exceptions and this is something i found
very interesting doing this research
right so
on average uh
a wholesale offer will be 30 to 50 below
retail price which is what we see as the
kind of uh
average in the market it varies a lot
between markets and depending on the
circumstances but essentially that holds
true right but
half of the wholesalers that we looked
into
only offer one speech here or in fact
they don't offer one speaker they offer
one price
so they price the circuit even though
it's bitstream that they sell not
passive fiber
they price the circuit at the same price
no matter what speed you want in fact
one of the service providers the
wholesellers that we spoke to
very interestingly said
we will build into the system whatever
speed tiers
our retail customers want
so they have the full freedom of saying
this is exactly how i want to tailor my
offer
in other words the wholesaler does not
impose his
his segmentation onto his retailers in
this particular instance but
others basically say well we offer
speeds up to a gigabit and the price is
the same no matter what speed you decide
to subscribe to
um and and i think that's an interesting
trend because it highlights uh one
element that i find very interesting
which is there's a complexity systems
wise in
enabling a lot of
of different
wholesale products
and so basically what these
uh wholesalers are saying is that
complexity is not worth it in terms of
the revenues that it will
the extra revenues it will generate it's
just not worth it
and so we might as well have a single
price
i think that's an interesting trend and
hopefully
it highlights to their retail customers
that
they don't have to segment to access
like they're often doing today now as i
said there are exceptions
we also have in the sample a wholesaler
that has 16 different speed tiers in
their wholesale offer which is
insane but
you know so
not everyone is is
ahead of the curve in
you can this
a bit on market by market of course
indeed yeah
but but maybe service providers are more
focused on on generating
additional revenue from value added
services for instance because we talk
about internet and data connectivity but
while you added services coming the game
as well
so uh what we did for this piece of work
is we we reviewed the complete set of
services from every single one of the
providers we looked into and if you look
at the graph here on the left it looks
like there's a lot of services on offer
but actually on average a given operator
only offers four additional services to
the broadband offer
which is quite low and most of these
services are actually not included
in the broadband packages
or sometimes they're included only in
the premium package but that suggests to
me
that these services are there for
adoption more than they are for
uh revenue generation in other words you
need to have these services in your
package to attract consumers
but you don't expect that they will
generate a lot of revenue so
without having looked at the numbers it
suggests to me
that um if the strategy is to say well
we don't necessarily want our customers
on higher speed tiers because we're
happy selling them additional services
it doesn't look to me from examining the
offers like that is particularly
successful either
now
there's one interesting shift though
from a few years ago and that is that
we're clearly seeing now that iptv is
dying so i mean the be all and end-all
of fiber offers
a decade ago was you have to offer your
own tv platform because that's the
differentiator that's going to make
people go from their dsl to the fiber
offer
10 years on
basically streaming is the name of the
game
and
a lot of the operators actually
embed
uh streaming tv content in their offers
or offer them as options so they act
effectively as distributors
to the disney pluses who lose
hbos and netflix's of this world
which is
a little bit ironic if i may because we
hear the operators complaining all the
time
that these large platforms are eating
their lunch by using their their network
but at the same time they're the ones
who are actually pushing these
uh
products to the end consumer which which
i found to be quite paradoxical and like
similarly uh we hear a lot about uh you
know gaming offers or or gaming segments
tailoring the broadband experience for
gamers because i mean on paper that
makes sense gamers are
a lot more sensitive to
uh specific
um you know latency issues things that
basically your average consumer might
not be uh so so worried about they're
going to be more
aware of i'm sure everyone's heard this
story uh that 10 years ago online
players were
convinced that the swedes were the best
in the world and they didn't want to
play them and actually the reality was
the swedes had better broadband so their
latency was lower so they always reacted
faster when you were on a a shooting
game for example um so you know for sure
that's a segment where there's value to
be extracted but actually only three
operators in the entire sample have
gaming packages and when you look at
what these packages are
two out of three are actually just
embedded uh microsoft xbox 360.
so
you've just feel like there's some
potential there but it's not really
being
addressed in any meaningful way um so
the only services where i think
they show future potential um and i
think when i saw them they tended to be
packaged in a relatively intelligent way
even though they are partnership uh
offerings were home security and home
automation
services particularly around home
security uh home automation sometimes is
also just uh devices and and you know
not actually an operated service but
it gave me the impression to be honest
that there's been a lot of talk these
last few years about innovative services
on the service provider site
but there's not a lot of reality to it
right now
so
clearly to me that's not where the
revenue generation is coming at least
today
indeed all right i fully understand so
it's very yet it's very spread out i
fully understand
but as
sales happen more and more online let's
move to that promotional aspect
how do you see that service provider are
using online tools to channel
that
the customer to to gigabit for instance
how do you see that
i was very surprised to be honest uh
at how
clunky the online channels were
um
i mean
if you
anticipate that basically
phone call-ins plus online is gonna be
ninety 90 of your cells which i think is
true today in most places
then you want those to be easy to
understand streamlined
uh clear
and
for the most part they're not
you struggle to find the offers often
fixed and mobile are mixed together so
it's very hard to understand exactly
what you are
talking about even harder when you you
know throw wi-fi into the mix and all of
that because it's presented as wireless
and
it's just very hard to understand
uh in general what you would be buying
and then you add to that the large
number of packages
and it becomes even harder to understand
because
the packages are not just different
speeds there are different sets of
services attached to them as well and in
some cases the same services but it's
it's free in the premium package and you
have to pay for it in the
non-premium package and
often these services also have options
so for example just your your wi-fi
extension thing right depending on your
number of room number of devices not
going to be the same price
it's really really complicated to
actually know what you're buying uh and
i mean i consider myself you know a
telecom marketing expert and sometimes i
was struggling to see
if you know things as simple as uh you
know voice voiceover ip were included or
not included or even available um
and you know like you see a
a poster an advert uh that has someone
with a phone so you might assume that
voice is included but then when you look
at the actual detail of the offer it's
mentioned nowhere and it's only finally
by clicking on a contract and you find
the line number 565 that you see that
there is a voip service
so
i really think actually that there's a
huge potential for
efficiency in these online channels that
hasn't been tapped into yet and
that combined with this clear strategy
could be a real way to accelerate the
monetization for sure
[Music]
so the promotional tools
well
yeah
yeah so so i mean obviously advertising
is a is a big thing i won't spend too
much time on that but essentially uh
what we see is that depending on
uh where the market is when it comes to
fiber the advertising is very different
right so in the early stages you want
people to become aware of fiber
so all of your advertising is going to
be on
uh you know kind of
uh
presenting the fiber as a product so
there's lots of lights in these adverts
there's lots of
technology elements and then pushing the
message that it's the fast broadband etc
but these are relatively simple kind of
educational
adverts we don't see them in western
europe very much anymore but obviously
we see them in other markets
where fiber isn't quite so uh
so prevalent
then there's a middle section where
everybody's fighting to acquire
customers and then it's more about
performance so you're going to be you
know
hearing words like power and everywhere
and gigabit and future and speed and
stuff like that
and then once the market is kind of
mature and settled it becomes more about
lifestyle so then you see
you know things like working from home
you see families represented a lot of
emphasis on customer service um so it's
not so much about the performance
anymore it's more about the ease of use
and the
the you know ease of contract etc
now the the second aspect of the
marketing or kind of promotional side of
course is is on the price and so here we
see basically half of our sample
uh have
uh contract duration promotion so if you
commit
to a year or more you get discounts uh
and essentially
uh what we see is that the the biggest
benefit actually is on one year contract
generally
because you get about a third off
of your entire year's cost on a one-year
contract
and interestingly enough
those that do two-year contracts you
also get a third of a year off so you're
you're not getting
obviously they're not offering one or
two year contracts they're offering one
or the other but when they're offering
two-year contracts it's it's not as
beneficial usually and then there was
one exception someone who offered a
three-year contract and basically
three-year contract you had one year
free which is the same as having 30 off
off a one-year contract but
you'd be locked in for three years um
but that's really the only promotional
tool that we saw there's a few instances
of devices being given away so for
example a wi-fi repeater uh would be
given away if you use if you contract it
for a year or stuff like that but
essentially that's really it so not a
huge amount of innovation there either i
felt
okay i understand
um so in fact
if we uh if we summarize that what what
the disturbance providers indeed do to
truly
embrace the gigabit era in fact today
as a sort of conclusion
yeah so so i mean uh hopefully i've i've
managed to convey the fact that i think
it's in their interest to actually have
a dedicated strategy to push
customers towards gigabit or to
establish
gigabit as kind of a baseline
in terms of the speeds that they offer
in order to do that i think the first
thing most important thing maybe is they
have to rationalize and reduce the
number of packages so they have to
recreate differentiation
which will have
two
beneficial effects that consumers will
perceive the difference
and also
that it will mathematically flatten the
price curve and reduce these huge gaps
in pricing
that basically position gigabit as
premium
whereas there's no cost reason to
actually do that at least not in those
proportions
um then
then the other thing is it
and this is just common marketing
uh issue uh
in any market right is if you have a set
of progressively
uh more performing
products then the one that's at the end
of the line the most effective product
will always be kind of perceived as
premium by the consumers anyway
so one way to address that is actually
to launch offers beyond a gigabit which
with the implementation of xgs pawn and
networks now becomes actually a very uh
you know feasible uh possibility and in
fact one of the interesting findings uh
in our uh in our analysis is that
consumers
sorry uh service providers who offer
speeds above a gigabit actually have
lower price gaps between a hundred and a
gig
because the premium has now shifted to
two or five or ten or eight well
technically um
so i think that's that's also an
important element and
uh it's also an important element in
terms of image because
uh just in the same way that the first
operators to launch gigabit in in any
given market
actually benefited from an image point
of view that and acquired consumers
from their competitors maybe not at
gigabit speeds but
basically it made their network look
like the most performing the most
effective network and i think that's
another benefit of launching speeds
beyond the gigabit now but in order to
benefit from that you have to be the
first one to do it because if
everybody's doing it at the same time no
one benefits
and
and then uh and then this last point
which is a very practical point is
uh yeah these these online channels need
to be worked at the user experience is
is really atrocious and and
so i think the service providers need to
uh maybe take a a you know a leaf
from the book of of online companies uh
you know do some serious a b testing
about how they structure their websites
in order to funnel
the the consumer towards
uh you know what they want them to
subscribe to which it which
is or should be in my opinion the
gigabit offers
so uh you know obviously each individual
case is going to be different and and uh
you know we're happy to offer assistance
in figuring out how to do it exactly but
but the point is that um you know these
at least are are four elements that i
think really really need to be addressed
if if gigabit is going to really pick up
and and again
the the the benefits in terms of margin
will be absolutely uh immediate if uh if
they do that
yeah
indeed
well thank you very much for uh for
bringing your expertise here benoit uh
it was very very interesting very useful
um i see a question
in popping up in the question list
so i will
the question is do you agree that fiber
optics offers
should have a price lower than 5g at
parity of speed and service
considering that fiber optics consumes
much lower energy than 5g
well i mean
it's interesting because that
when you say it like that there's an
assumption that every offer should
perfectly reflect costs in the real
world that's not how it works right uh
sure a louis vuitton handbag costs more
to produce
than the average leather handbag but it
doesn't cost 20 times more to produce so
you know how you position your pricing
is not solely a cost based decision
so the real question to me should be
are you offering both if you're offering
both then you need to adjust your
pricing so that
um you get the customers where you want
them if you want them to have both 5g
and fiber then you need to think about
uh you know the two prices in relation
to each other maybe even group the
offers so that they can buy both
at a at a discount uh but if your
competitors are offering 5g then yeah
you definitely want to be below that
price and then if you're the mobile
operator offering 5g you want to be
lower than your fiber offer so it's hard
to have a hard and fast rule it's really
about market circumstances now if the
question is is it cheaper to run a fiber
broadband offer at equivalent speed to a
5g
mobile broadband offer in terms of opex
i think there's no doubt that it is
the the
huge benefit there
of of fiber is that it's a very flat
cost structure there's very few variable
costs whereas
uh energy and spectrum and all of that
creates actually
a larger variable cost basis on the
mobile side
yeah indeed yeah and i would also add to
that that the mobile type of offerings
of fixed or fixed offerings are having
some conceptual differences as well
because
mostly unlimited in fixed type of where
you have more let's say
download volume limits in more mobile
type of usage we'll see how that evolves
of course but there are some elements
that are different when you talk about
the connectivity model
or concept for fixed or for or for
mobile as such
yeah and and also it's mobile i mean
that's the benefit you're paying for as
well is that you get it everywhere
yes indeed but it's mostly done up to of
course yeah with the gig you also
speeds are not so much defined in the
mobile world than than than in the fixed
one
okay and next question we see in many
markets ftth services sold at the
doorstep as the main sales channel
do you see consistent data to show how
gigabit services are primarily purchased
do you have an insight on that one
um
so it's true that
in early stages of market deployment
doorstep sales
have proven to be very effective it's
also a very expensive channel
so
my impression is that once a market
reaches maturity
that no longer is the primary
uh sales channel
basically once you get to a critical
mass
of coverage which means you can start to
do national advertising
whether it's above the line or below the
line doesn't really matter
um then
you want customers to come to you either
calling you or going on the website
and
as soon as you can guarantee to them
that they can actually get the fiber if
their the house is not already connected
then
that's a much more efficient channel so
it's really um a question of maturity in
in
uh in you know like typically in the
netherlands 10 years ago yes a lot of
those sales
were done door-to-door i don't think
it's the case anymore
and
here in france similarly i don't think
there is anyone doing door to door sales
anymore so it's really down to
um you know where you are in the courage
and advertising story
then by the way it was timon wrote that
was asking that question i have also mr
rui duarte who asked for the uh
for the copy of the flight and of course
they will be made available so that's
not a problem
um
in fact uh if i may
uh
we are also distributing the full report
so it's not just the slides that are
going to be available there's a
what is it 12 page
uh report that goes in a lot more detail
on the numbers on
all kinds of specifics so uh you know
make sure you download that as well
because it complements what we've been
discussing here very well
exactly exactly
we have some some spare time for some
additional questions i think so we
talked about the wholesale and retail
models
so um why is it more in the interest of
the wholesaler to encourage higher speed
for instance according to uma
well i mean first of all
wholesale models don't rely on a lot of
um
like additional services right maybe you
can have
various sla options or
that kind of stuff but essentially all
of the value creation that is going to
happen in the market is going to happen
above your network not within your
network
this is uh i mean
something that's been
discussed a lot
with you know things like slicing et
cetera down the line that there might
actually be some opportunities to uh
deliver a multiplicity of services
beyond broadband
uh through a wholesale channel but it's
not the reality of the market today
so
i think if you're a wholesaler
your core focus is on
making sure that the end user which you
have no direct relationship with
is not going to shift to another network
right so
you want him to have the best possible
broadband because that's what's going to
keep him on the broadband
essentially your business model is
predicated on
your number of end users only going up
never going down
so what you want is
someone who's happy and if they're not
happy they're gonna go to another
provider on the same network that's your
business model sorted right so i think
introducing complexity in your wholesale
offers is not in your interest for that
very reason right you want the simplest
smoothest easiest relationship that you
can set up and
like segmenting like crazy introduces a
lot of complexity in the systems in the
relationship in the consumer choice so i
don't think really that it's in your
interest
ideally ideally you would want all of
the consumers to be on gigabit already
today
because they would be getting a better
experience and the the marginal benefit
that you would be getting from selling
higher tiers
i don't think is worth as much as the
guarantee that they're not moving and
that they're happy
yeah indeed indeed
i have another question from paul
thompson who wants to go back to the
added services we discussed
so um which do you see driving the need
for higher speeds because even 4k
netflix is up 50 megabits per second
is it virtual reality is it immersive
video conferencing is it this kind of
or are there other ones you see there
popping up
so
for the last 10 years now at least i've
been saying that
there is no killer app uh remember 10
years ago everybody was talking about
killer apps we don't use this expression
anymore and i think everyone's kind of
realized that
it's in many ways the wrong way of
looking at the world
um
the the
the the core of my thought process on
this is essentially goes in two
directions right direction number one is
speed cells
so consumers
i mean they have no way
of
estimating
whether
what they need before they have the
broadband installed right so
this is why
uh when the first lockdown came in
operators were getting flooded by calls
of people saying well my broadband is
too
bad for what i needed now right so
in that sense
the killer app was four people in the
home using broadband simultaneously
it wasn't any particular thing that they
were doing it was just that they were
all pulling on the same resource at the
same time and in actual fact just to be
clear
the saturation was not happening in the
access it was happening in the
aggregation because this is where
dimensioning uh you know with all the
statistical multiplexing going on etc
the dimensioning was simply insufficient
and that's why
when we saw we did a study a couple of
years ago on the first lockdowns to try
and estimate what happened exactly and
for sure the first two or three weeks
you saw a clear degradation in
performance but within three weeks it
had been fixed because these were
aggregation links that needed more
capacity and that's very easy for an
operator to upgrade
so
the point is that uh you know that drove
demand for higher speeds
because up front people didn't realize
they needed it the minute they were in a
different circumstance they needed it
and and i don't think they'll be going
back because
they they've been through this
experience now
but having said that from a marketing
standpoint we know that speed sells
provided that
the the revenue uplift that you're
expecting from it isn't too important so
this is back to the premium point that
we were uh highlighting i am absolutely
convinced that if your gigabit offer
is 20 more expensive than your 100 meg
offer and you do a concerted marketing
effort to get people to upsell you'll
get great success on the upsell
so that's one aspect right so it's
really independent of what people are
doing it
doing with it to a certain extent now of
course we are anticipating down the line
some applications that will require
either
very high capacity or
very low latency or both so
you know vr et cetera for sure now the
the the question mark that i have is
um
do we
anticipate that 50 of households are
gonna have vr sets within
five years i don't see it
i may be wrong and it'd be great for
vendors and you know and and uh
application providers if i was wrong but
i just don't see it so
um you don't build your network strategy
on the basis of
uh you know
a niche market you you you build it on
the basis of what most consumers are
going to want to buy which is a
different thing than what they need
right remember we don't need
uh 1200 dollar handsets we would be
doing 95 of what we're doing with 300
handsets
but people are buying 1200 handsets
because they want to so from a marketing
standpoint i don't think building the
network strategy on an understanding of
what the need is
is where you need to be you need to look
at what your internal needs are where
are you saturating and i know from
having talked to a lot of operators that
they see their pawn saturating in some
areas
and this is what drives the adoption of
xgs pawn
once you have xgspawn then marketing can
take over and say okay what should i
sell 2gig five gig
whatever and how do i sell it but
there's not i think you know 8k tv it'll
come but all of these things will
actually the ecosystem will evolve
afterwards not before i suppose is what
i'm saying so i think the key drivers
are going to happen
once the infrastructure is at least
partly in place and actually this allows
me to touch upon a point that a lot of
people dismiss but i think is important
uh remember how
when we were all on dial-up and then a
few
you know privileged people started
migrating to dsl and they were saying oh
my god everything is so fast and then
within a few years
everything was not so fast anymore and
dial-up was unusable
that's because the entire online
ecosystem adjusted to hey everybody's
got dsl now
and
gradually slowly the same thing is
happening
with
every website out there now right the
the basic assumption is that you have
fiber speeds
at least 100 make if not more and so
your online experience if you're still
on dsl today or if you're on a 50 meg
package your online experience is now
degrading just like dial-up was
degrading 20 years ago
um the the shift is more gradual but
it's still
happening and so
i think as
as service providers
uh
or no well i'm not a service provider
service providers need to
uh to realize that part of the
uh evolution of their own offers is also
following that trend so there's a very
interesting example with chorus in new
zealand for example last december
they uh they basically increased the
speeds of their basic packages without
charging more
just because they need to adjust to the
fact that people are now using these
basic packages differently and so the
purpose is not an upsell it's just to
deliver a service that allows people to
do what they wanted to do with it
because they don't feel like their use
has changed that much
but the need from a network standpoint
did and so i think that's very smart
thinking this is how you keep your
customers as well
exactly exactly
now you mentioned the network um and as
a last question i would like to say um
we talk about more and more speed for
consumers we talk about bigger bit
monetization gigabit speed
um but that additional capacity that you
have then
in the network does that not compromise
if you talk about these other services
or other segments for business or for
mobile transport or whatever on your
file infrastructure
so so what's what's really interesting
and this is we're really at the very
beginning of that trend right but what's
really interesting is that as these
higher uh
uh
speed network technologies are being
implemented xgs pawn 25g
also in parallel we see
uh
the the virtualization of the network uh
becoming more and more of a reality and
that opens up a very important
capability when it comes to fixed
networks which is fixed network slicing
slicing is a term that's used a lot in
the mobile space but actually in the
fixed space it has very
clear and practical applications in
order to basically
shell i suppose could be a word or
tunnel specific
uh
traffics within the network to to
shelter them from
excessive usage so if you are using your
xgspawn network for mobile backhoe
you can use slicing to ensure that that
mobile backhoe will not be affected by
anything else that happens on the
network and this is a way to effectively
replicate
multiple physical networks without
having to deploy multiple physical
networks and so the way that i see this
is that this is the only way that this
one network vision can actually
become a reality because we still need
from a logical standpoint to be able to
separate the business market from the
mobile backhaul or mobile front hole
and from the residential customers um
and and slicing is actually the way to
do that and it's interesting you know
these
trends in in technology because a few
years ago
like everybody was talking about slicing
now it's like nobody's talking about it
anymore but it's still there it's still
happening and it really is a very
important step that uh you know we need
to
keep in mind and operators need to
put a lot of
uh thought process into because the the
big benefit of this one network vision
is going to be the ability to switch off
the copper to switch off the dedicated
fiber links to
mobile masts once you can really manage
this as a single network i mean some
operators are managing effectively four
or five networks in parallel the opex
and energy cost of that not to mention
the sustainability angle it's absurd we
absolutely need to have that as a
priority agenda for operators
absolutely
and with that as an excellent uh closing
i would like to close this session
um i don't see any additional questions
anymore
well thank you very much
yes
thank you
yeah i was gonna say thanks to everyone
who attended and uh obviously feel free
to uh reach out if you have any
additional questions uh don't forget to
download the the white paper
and uh and thanks to you eric and to the
council for uh hosting this it was a
pleasure thank you very much and see you
next time bye